Sit down here.
Okay, you can sit.
Sit this way.
Oh, you, um,
you gonna review this one first?
Oh, sure.
Okay.
So you can play and then pause
if you want to
tell something. Sure.
Okay.
You can talk
and explain what you were thinking.
Yeah.
Well, I would say, like,
um...
So you mean, explain, like,
which motion
like to say, or... Yeah, um,
you can, you can say,
you know, um,
you can go through this one. Yeah.
Mm.
Describe what you were thinking
and what you were feeling at each moment.
For me, I would say
when I'm doing push-ups,
I would just, like,
sometimes I would just confirm for the next step.
Sometimes I'm not sure for the next step.
Even though, like, I practiced so many times,
it would make me, like,
feeling, like, because it's competition,
you would feel nervous,
and it would affect your motion.
Like, in this example,
like, I forgot one motion,
movement.
In my natural
motion, I would just
step to do it again.
But it's not a step in the competition.
It may be do the wrong thing
in the competition. So, yeah.
And also...
Yeah, it may be
feeling some
stressful.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Thank you.